[Music]
you there boy what day is this christmas
eve sir oh yeah you thick or something
kids but to be fair the doctor should
not be surprised at this reaction after
907 years give or take a regeneration or
two he should probably be aware that
this is a question that will immediately
raise some questions of the hey you're
weird variety year of our lord 1851 sir
right last year
only if you ignore the publishing of
moby dick the founding of the new york
times in the first ever photographic of
a solar eclipse but sure it was a bit
dull in the uk so let's just write off
the whole year
[Music]
getting this excited to hear someone
scream your name outside of a bedroom
the doctor probably sounded like a
pretty badass alias when he first left
galafrey but at this point wouldn't it
make more sense to change it to dr who
no just the doctor yes it's bigger on
the inside no it's not an actual
screwdriver yes i have great hair and
just save us all some time i'm the
doctor
simply the doctor the one the only and
the best vanity by proxy oh that's new
the writers of the show very naively
thought that having the faux doctor
exclaimed this would trick the audience
into believing that this mildly
steampunk cyberman mask on an ikea rug
would qualify it as something new to
enjoy it did not i've been hunting this
piece for a good fortnight doctors who
mention a good fortnight without then
flossing then i suggest you let go what
they look at least three stories high
and the not doctor suggesting he could
just let go do you want regenerated ants
because this is how you get regenerated
ants how do both doctors crown this
window and breach instead of head first
like they were clearly hanging just
seconds ago two sets of doctor bottoms
survive this
the next doctor we're all homeless hello
hope i don't just trip over a brick
that'd be embarrassing then again
painless
worst ways to go to be honest the brick
itself has very little to do with the
pain part of dying for example tripping
over a brick into a pile of pillows
would be amazing however not amazing
tripping over a brick into a swirling
vortex of nothingness filled with the
memories of every missed opportunity and
every poor decision you've ever made
while being prodded with a million
toothpicks as you scream from the bottom
of your lungs please make it stop make
it stop or having to watch the trial of
a time lord as it's more commonly known
but i've heard all about you doctor
a bit of a legend i say so myself
modesty forbids me to agree with you sir
but yes yes i am oxymoronic modesty
oxymorodesty ah don't blink remember
that
whatever you do don't blink the blinking
and the statues hey guys remember that
really good episode the one everyone
loves hold on to that memory while you
watch this far less entertaining episode
also as if the evil cyborgs weren't
enough now we're referencing the
over-emotional angel demons too too many
nemesis doctor we haven't even mentioned
the sociopathic trash cans yet it's been
a pleasure mr smith this man has had the
vast majority of his memories wiped away
but for some reason is happy to leave
behind the one person who seems to be
able to help him fill in the gaps the
cyber king will rise
indeed
wait what was that look was that a
robona reference is someone just a bit
too excited to play with their new
erector set this league of extra board
and steri gentlemen scene clops on for
some time
now
with the house empty i shall affect an
entrance of the rio title of my sex tape
this is hardly work for a woman the next
doctor survives this the memories of a
time lord
can be contained within a watch would
you mind it's sad
if it's opened
oh
maybe not clock teasers they are info
stumps ah yes info stamps the latest in
a long line of convenient whovian
technology famously proceeded by plot
propellers disbelief suspenders and nick
of time pieces i've seen one of these
before did elon musk attempt to fly it
to space
help me
ah
two words i never issued i know a fair
amount of wear and a few thousand
vervoids and a young man from elsarius
that would take issue with that
statement
discount daleks also i find it hard to
believe that the clunking boots of the
cybermen would have gone unnoticed which
means they must have already been in
position and hung around just long
enough for the doctor's who to find the
clues they need and bond a bit before
attacking how thoughtful i think we
should run the doctor tells someone to
run cliche
are the cyber persons programmed to wait
to knock down doors until the doctor is
nearby because this is the third time
this has happened and the timing is an
iron giant convenience what exactly was
the doctor expecting from this umbrella
that would summon mary poppins it was
secretly sonic mjolnir in disguise
engaging in close quarters combat was
zappy-handed murder bots instead of
continuing to run away while their speed
is still set to michael myers
staring your beneficence upon the poor
bestowing your beneficence upon the poor
or anybody without their explicit
consent but that's why the late reverend
fairchild had to die miss hartigan
spends a fierce amount of time mustache
twirling and plan explaining instead of
immediately sending in the cyberdyne
rejects does she not realize i have to
wait until this is over before i can
enjoy my leftover turkey sandwiches get
on with it these pigs in a poke just
stand here waiting to die instead of
trying to escape not saying they would
have made it i'm just saying there's
probably a better strategy than mull
around quizzically until the villain
clearly exposes your death what about
the tardis oh she's ready come on i'm
looking forward to this oh my dear
doctor i'd suggest you lower those
expectations quite drastically just a
bit of advice i wish i'd had ahead of
the reveal of a [ __ ] hot air balloon
instead of a shiny new tire disk to geek
as him over also that's right i said
terdes we go by the every acronym letter
must be pronounced like the word it's
from dictate passed down after the gif
wars of the 2040s it was all settled at
the new geneva convention in 2047. and
where's the tardis now in the yard
uh
it was all this luggage little known
fact originally the title of this
episode was slated to be david tennant
just walks around asking questions but
some marketing company thought that was
too long doctor the answer to all this
is in your tardis can i see it
mr smith it would be my honor replacing
a tenant with a smith tardis
t-a-r-d-i-s it stands for tethered
aerial release developed in style then i
believe you mean territus also why did
he choose to build a balloon in the
first place and why would the acronym
change lake's memories have been wiped
and replaced with the doctor so
shouldn't he be hard at work building a
blue wooden box mr cole mr schoons mr
fetch and mr milligan she sounds like
she's either starting a joke or a logic
puzzle and honestly it's a sin either
way also we're halfway into this
christmas special and the doctor has
been more involved in solving the case
of the pointing spider who meme than
whatever is going on here so honestly
every time it cuts to the devil in the
red dress my brain says skip little test
turn right
turn left considering ms hardigan didn't
specify how much they should turn
shouldn't the turn left command have put
them back into their original stance
instead of making them do a full 180
degree turn yes i'm watching a scene
where a group of individuals is being
mind controlled by steampunk bluetooth
headsets to do all the bidding of
cybernetic suits of armors from space
and i'm taking issue with the
trigonometry of it all are you really
surprised instead of mentally coercing a
human to operate this carriage ms
hardigan has opted for the far more
conspicuous cyber wookie option and of
course no one will notice the story
begins with the cyberman if you looked
up the ingredients for doctor who
christmas specials the top ingredient
would be doctor who sits down and
explains some hulu to unknowing humans
followed closely of course by monosodium
glutamate that's in everything these
days but it's everything you could want
to know
about the doctor well everything you
could want to know about the doctors
that have appeared on screen so far
spoiler sweetie also where did the
daleks even get this footage from and
why would they need it this should just
be a bunch of text describing all the
ways the doctor has defeated them next
to an infographic explaining how stairs
work the invention building a tardis
that's all you the hot air balloon as we
know it can be traced back to france in
the 1780s all lake here is invented is a
new way for the english to steal credit
for something that already exists like
biscuits sorry
really i am so sorry the doctor tells
someone he's sorry cliche
so we're just naming the best doctor who
episodes of all time now are you
genuinely trying to make me realize how
poorly this one compares the doctor
needs help
there should be someone at his side yes
because it's not doctor who unless he
has a squishy human at his side with a
distinct lack of regenerative abilities
to make saving the world significantly
more difficult hey doc just trying to
make sure this one doesn't get blown
into space prematurely aged or married
off to a barbarian king there's a good
chap all the sewage runs through there
straight into the thames river pong
oh that's cheating sneaking out
give your legs on silent the writers
seem to believe that acknowledging a
plot convenience will excuse them from
relying upon it it will not you could be
quiet
i doubt he paid you to talk rosita could
be the most ineffectual companion we've
ever seen i love the actor but she's
given nothing to work with not even a
witty response to this put down from
hardigan i get that lake needed a
companion to finish the whole package i
just wish the writers had bothered to
create one worth caring about i'm the
doctor doctor who says i'm the doctor
cliche at this point i'm thinking about
starting up a doctor who bingo card for
these christmas specials feel free to
show your interest in the comments and
i'll send one out to you last year
man jl is all over the place goes from
arrogantly thinking he's the doctor to
dramatically mourning the death of his
wife and now to full-on convenient
deucing these literal ex-machinas
badassery in the span of an hour tell
your masters we're not waiting till dawn
the cyber king will rise tonight
of all the mondassinine ideas why in the
name of the good vord our savior are you
waiting until dawn in the first place
showing brain a dimension
stolen from the daleks again apparently
this year the cybermen are sponsored
exclusively by the daleks they're meant
to be a highly intelligent race of
cybernetic organisms but between this
copper nipple doodad and the
expositional infotubes the cybermen have
barely had to do a damn thing for
themselves since when did they become
the paclids of the hooniverse jackson is
this it the thing you couldn't remember
i don't think so
i just can't see
it's like it's hidden like some sort of
scriptwriter needed to hold that
information for an underwhelming
surprise later there's a whole pie for
everyone if you like it i don't know man
i was thinking about sticking around
kind of looking forward to watching all
of these other kids die a painful death
by electrocution before i'm turned into
a stompy murder man what flavor pie are
we talking about here where are all the
cyberpunks there's apparently a legion
of reutered c-3pos up here hailing their
new queen and only one guarding the
entire workforce that their plan hinges
upon
[Music]
melodrama of melodrama is melodrama to
increase melodramatic melodrama cliche
melodrama but he's alive doctor
frederick come on and of course he just
happens to be the only child to stay
behind even as all the other children
around him fled like the good little
obedient plot device he is it's like
this
is it feces because i bet it's feces
it's a cyber king
the cyber king is what great question
it's apparently an iron giant rip-off
where instead of being several different
killer robots with the ability to
accomplish many tasks it's one large
robot that can accomplish a single much
less flexible task because it looks cool
designed by apple i'm guessing the
doctor who franchise has given us some
great science fiction stories for over
50 years but even in the 21st century
i'm taken out of the adventure by these
over-ambitious attempts at special
effects the terrorist is a work of set
design artistry the doctor is always an
unthrowing on-screen presence a ship
like this doesn't even belong in wallace
and grommet jackson you've got your son
you've got a reason to live cool i think
i'm understanding now in order to have a
reason to live i need to create
offspring got it thanks pop culture
people of the world now hear me people
of the world how are they supposed to be
hearing this there's no radios or
televisions to transmit through you'll
barely be heard on the other side of the
thames let alone the rest of the planet
your governments will surrender and if
not
then behold my power ultimatums are
great but they work better if the
governments in question are aware they
exist and if you hold fire on the death
and destruction until they've at least
had an opportunity to respond at this
rate the only way she'll create an army
of cyber people is by spooning the
squishy remains of humanity into suits
of armor one ladle at a time
in the name of razalon's rabbit rabbits
what the hell is he doing sure hot air
balloons are cool but how about we try
the actual [ __ ] tardis you know the
one blue box bigger on the inside
capable of actual directional flight
missed heart again
i'm offering you a choice this
conversation is a lie all they should be
able to hear through the engine and
clonking gears
is hurting
[Music]
why would i leave this place
because if you don't
i'll have to stop you at some point they
could just cut these two lines out and
put them in every who story arc ever i'm
just saying it would save on production
costs probably then i have made you a
failure
your weapons are useless sir premature
self-cyber rating he's killed it
but whatever he did he's killed it and
now it will stumble around stomping
houses and killing a few dozen more
people before he actually magically
whoses it away and all hail the savior
of the earth if the wand of time warping
can just poof the cybir and giant into a
vortex of doom what was the point of all
the mind opening and vaporizing a few
seconds ago i guess that the doctor had
to get up here to give hartigan the
chance to surrender but by gallofry that
was an unnecessarily painful way to go
but not once no sir not once not ever
has he ever been thanked citation needed
but no more
for i say to you on this christmas morn
bravo sock bravo does not mean thank you
bravo means great job or well done you
can actually tell someone they did a
good job without being thankful to them
like requiem for a dream for example
bravo aronofsky but no thank you well
this is nonsense the governor would be
excellent at tv sins
deleted
that felt great what's next
[Music]
guaranteed fresh
toady fish away and it
[Music]
at this time the males are totally
docile a united and cooperative team
they brace against the storm by merging
their thousand bodies into a single mass
would you mind asking
is that your sonic screwdriver
or are you just pleased to see me
oh it's just
me
whistling
[Music]
who are you
i'm batman
in all these years not one of you has
asked my first name
just say it
there she is the tardis what the [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about you know
all about me and i know all about you i
don't care about any of that we're here
to move forward
[Music]
[Music]